under the influence of a family
physician I had entered Gettysburg
College as a nominal pre-med preparing
for medical school although I really
wasn't all that motivated to become a
doctor and what I discovered against
Berg College was that the liberal arts
were wonderful
I I took the minimum amount of science
courses to qualify for medical school
although I liked them I like science
from the get-go
I also liked literature and philosophy
and I took courses and those to the
maximum degree possible within the
context of what I had to do to get into
medical school it came time to apply to
medical school I wasn't at all sure
where I wanted to go most accomplished
graduates of Gettysburg College who
wanted to go to medical school went to
the University of Pennsylvania it was
more or less a sure thing because Penn
knew the school well and trusted the
faculty but my adviser who was a
treasured friend and professor of
chemistry called me in one day to chat
and said well Mike you have to apply to
medical school this year yes sir what do
you want to do and I said well I don't
know I'm I'm sort of interested in an
academic career I had no clue what that
meant I had never seen a research lab
there was no research at Gettysburg
College at the time I had never met a
research scientist but I saw my faculty
at this college and I liked what I saw
of their lifestyle and what they were
consumed with doing then you should
apply to Harvard and I said where's that
I had literally never heard of it just
as I had never heard of evolution before
and his response was in Boston somewhere
I think so I applied to Harvard and I
applied to Penn and I was admitted to
both Harvard of course sent a telegram
penn said the first class
and I was forced then confronted with
how to make the choice and I was reinter
viewed at Penn by the the vice dean for
academic affairs for a scholarship so I
made a second trip to Philadelphia and
he asked me the same question what do
you want to do and I told him getting
the same answer I'm kind of interested
in academic career he said well where
have you been admitted
I said Harvard and here and this Penn
Dean said well you should probably go to
Harvard and I did but not before finally
visiting Harvard I wrote to them and
said I've been admitted to Penn in
Harvard and I'm having trouble deciding
between the two could I come visit and
they responded oh yes we'll pay your way
and come on up
and I went up and it was it was a
complete fraternity rush I mean I came
home with my head spinning about what
the place was like and five years later
I had an exit interview the dean of
students at Harvard did an admirable
thing he did an exit interview with
every student at the Harvard Medical
School and when I win to have my exit
interview he started by saying Mike
before we get into the exit interview I
just can't resist asking you whether you
remember that letter I said what letter
he said oh the letter about how you were
having trouble choosing between Penn and
Harvard oh yes I remember that he said
well I thought you'd like to know that
the staff thought that was so funny they
put it on a bulletin board
you